hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dark wood i can't
get enough of this game this game is
legitimately fascinating to me i just
desperately want to play it it's like
it's like 7am right now i just got up
and i was like i want to record another
episode of this because i want to know
what's going
on so that's a displody isn't it
i think the ones with the tentacles
going out through the abdomen are the
splody bodies
all right so i don't exactly know what
i'm looking for um i'm kind of on the
edge
here i could go south or it could go up
north beyond the pig pen and see what's
going on up there because if it's
anything like
that might not be a splody body or they
might all be splody bodies
no it's not um that's good actually let
me use the sticks
mostly just because they're pretty
common
and so i don't necessarily do i have a
lockpick damn i don't
uh i don't necessarily need one oh
mushroom
okay there's a box there at least it's
on my map and there's another box there
damn if only i had lock picks oh
don't trust that hey bud oh
oh
uh-huh yeah you pointed at me yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yum okay okay
it's got some range on it which is good
i don't need to get as close
oh yeah the range is great on that i
gotta use that to my advantage
um it's not so good probably for the
dogs cause those are just hard to dodge
period i don't need any logs right now
necessarily
that's probably okay moose please do not
charge me
please do not wire that's what i need i
need wire
lots of wire please oh my god i
gotta look out for the bear traps i'm
going to get
murdered and i'm so far from my base if
i respond
i'm never gonna get my stuff back
this is the pig pen interesting
hello hi
piggies
piggy piggies icky piggies
piggy
hey mush do i have space for you oh i do
i do because i already have one in my
inventory thanks piggy oh there's a
crate there too
why is this taking so long to open why
is it taking so long to open
i know another toolbox that sounds
incredibly useful
oh wait church ruins oh
the save must have opened up before that
actually happened okay but i found those
all right so that's good i've got two to
oh
so i gotta remember the squiggly
googlies means mushy washes
or i could say that a little less
stupidly tractor rear view mirror that's
probably important for something but i'm
i'm not able to come get it just yet i
told you he had it coming
don't mind me just invading your farm
totally fine oh
you know what
it's gonna be a hard no for me bud all
right
see you around never see you never i
will literally
never see you bear trap i just gotta be
more mindful this game
really is about patience like if you
rush into anything
you are dead honestly the little rocks
are probably weapons or distraction
tools
and i haven't utilized them yet but to
be honest i've been more concerned with
getting uh
the proper materials no no no no no no
no
no no no no no no no buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy yeah i've been worried
about getting the proper materials to be
able to craft everything that i need to
survive
which has been oddly tough this game is
very difficult oh
no okay so more bugs which is
great and another baby sack okay i'm at
the
tick farm apparently and just north of
here should be
whatever the path is to the northern
northern area
at least maybe i can get kind of like an
idea of what
obstacle i need bridge oh
oh no i seem safe
don't blow up you're not even dead
okay cool good great oh
oh that was a mistake oh big mistake big
mistake big mistake big mistake big
mistake
mistake mistake mistake mistake was made
yeah the bridge don't seem nice
the bridge seems like big bad really big
bad
oh boy there's a backpack there
so if i was ever feeling brave and
taking on a couple of those dudes which
i'm not
i i could
try to take those guys on but i really
don't want to okay this is the silo i
believe
you know i'm shocked before when i was
first starting playing this game in the
first few episodes that
i didn't just blindly run into every
bear and trap because i now realize
why the stamina bar is so low is because
you don't need to be running that far
unless you're running away from
something you got you really got to be
looking i need my lantern okay this is
good i need i know i need to put gas in
the generator
that's one thing i know i need to do but
i have
mushies for new essence
oh once a day i'll be able to run for a
short time once a day
i'll be we'll be able to see all around
me
my blood will hurt enemies honestly the
runner technique
sounds good because but how do i
activate these
that's what i don't know how do i turn
these on are these just always on or
how do i do this how about runner
and fearful i could also do acid blood
and fearful because i imagine the blood
would shoot out of my
eyes onto my enemies and therefore i
would get a little blinded
but i would they would get hurt but i'm
gonna go with running like i'm
so scared i can't possibly know where
i'm running
i'm gonna go with that oh
no no no i don't want to go into the
vision world no
no i don't want to do this
hi okay great no map here
awesome well time for oh belle
whom does that toll for the sound still
resonates inside this mossy bell
some tells me that ain't natural hello
uh
hello i stand in line
well there's really no line is there
the charred church roof bends under the
weight
of red oily clouds
oh oh no
i could repair this doorway do i have
nah yeah you know what oddly enough i
can't
oh you know can't you see who's
there's a line who do you think you are
excuse me oh hey line
hi i could open it with a
lock pick hello
hello
strange that is a strange box all right
that is a fantastically strange bomb
[Music]
oh god i do i didn't i wasn't ready for
that i would have been ready for that i
wasn't ready for that
i wasn't ready i was i wasn't ready
i wasn't ready for that a white dress a
red saw what do you mean
hi oh hello what are you doing here wolf
man
i mean what's with the big eyes scared
bad dream
the wolf winks at me bearing his teeth
slightly okay
strange box oh it's one of these the
wolf grabs the box and starts sniffing
it from every angle
i could swear i've heard his tail moving
under his coat an interesting find me
guess now you want to know what's inside
somewhere in the northwestern part of
the old woods
that's a place where you'll find a key
to this box mommy
i'll be careful if i were you trust me
you don't want to open it by yourself
bring me the key and don't try to be a
wise guy you won't know what to do with
it
all right great can i have this wire
thanks man thank you you are love you
i buy weapons and ammo i don't have
really that i got two sticks
you want stick i could give you stick i
will take your wire and i will give you
nothing deal
thanks hey thank you i needed that for
lockpick
okay are you just gonna be here for the
night
you want to stay i need to fill up the
generator um
i also have another mushroom not looking
forward to this next
trip okay i need to quickly uh upgrade
workshop
let's see what i can do i can now build
a homemade shotgun that's good
gasoline oh i no longer need toolbox
well i'm not gonna know that for certain
until
a little bit later i'm gonna do a hop
bar upgrade this time
uh it is one more but that's okay let's
get bandages and then let's go
fill in the generator and let's find out
what the hell is moaning
who's moaning who is moaning at me is it
wolf man
it is it is it's just wolf man it's
that's that's all he's just a heavy
breather
great let's actually had probably enough
for another night
but just in case because i imagine i'm
gonna be here for one more night i'm
probably gonna go to the village next
so i'm just gonna fill that up to there
let's go ahead and switch that on let's
get moving
yeah so the fact that this door down
here was just open did that mean that
i forgot to uh take care of that all
right wolf man i don't know how you're
gonna get out of here i guess you're
stuck with me for the night
i could put another bear trap down there
that'd probably be good
if i put another bear trap down here i'm
not gonna have a way out let me actually
i
won't do that i'm just gonna barricade
it and the bathtub is there to try to
help i guess
i don't know i guess i don't need the
toolbox then
i'll hold on to it just in case i don't
know with this game enough to be like oh
i don't need your toolbox anymore but i
can make a shovel at least if i have a
shovel head
hey do you have a shovelhead no you
don't what good are you
you're kind of useless ain't you i could
take a rag though i'll take a rag
thanks bud you're a real pal all right
baby let's do this
you ready for the night wolf man oh god
i don't like that his health bar shows
up i could attack him and i don't want
to
you just gonna disappear when the time
comes
maybe oh no he's
he's here oh well welcome to my
home for tonight i kind of don't like
that you're here actually
but it's nice to have another
soul i can't say person you're kind of a
wolf
a wolf person whoa okay well
hey there was there's no need
i'm kind of curious what the wolfman is
gonna do in response to this probably
nothing
oh no well good thing there's a trap
there
all right and i'm gonna whump you wonk
wonk wonk
barricade up the door again well that
was easy
they're making this too easy on me
glogg glorg want in
oh glorg smell meat
lord entering lord trapped
how could this happen to glorg wonka
sklorg
not glorg's valuable head glorg
oh sorry glorg man that's unfortunate
thanks for the stick though and the
alcohol the booze is great
hey these are pretty these are pretty
useful wolfman are you impressed by my
survival abilities
you impressed you better be impressed or
they'll come for you next
just kidding friend where am i i'm gonna
sell some of these staffs to them
trying to get another item yes me yes
hey what's up
you are making this night like
delightful by the way
this is like the first night where i
haven't been panicked out of my mind
so thank you for that i really do
appreciate it you're
just so nice oh hey
wrong door nerd man they made this night
easy man i think wolfman legitimately
made this night easy
i don't know if he was supposed to be
here by design but
man he made this night easy i mean my
bear traps did most of the work
all right well wolfman's gone hey bud
how are you doing
okay what do you got buddy uh more
fabric i do like fabric
i really like fabric but i don't know if
i have enough to trade with him
to be able to get that fabric oh the
shovel i can make a shovel
i do like the idea of that i can now
craft that and that's probably like a
vastly superior weapon to everything
that i have
i don't know what a knife is for besides
just being a weapon
the pill is actually interesting because
it was for running and not necessarily
for healing
so that is actually more useful than i
thought it was so if i'm ever in a
pickle i just pop a pill and then i go
running down the way i think the toolbox
is done
i don't think i need a toolbox anymore
so i'm just gonna operate under the
assumption that i do not i only
need one stick for the shovel and i'm
sure i'm gonna get more sticks
man pistol i could almost get that but i
i don't want to deal with the ammo for
that i'd rather have a really reliable
melee weapon
the lantern's basically done i'm gonna
work with torches for now
what do i do with the empty glass
bottles oh
you can make a molotov out of gas oh
okay
you can either do it with a pre-made
bottle of alcohol or you can make it out
of gas
interesting let's see how much this gets
me with these sticks here
this this this this and this what's that
going to give me is that enough
doesn't have enough room in his
inventory well that's unfortunate but
these are
basically worthless anyway let's try
this
four five oh the bread oh of course the
bread oh of course the bread oh of
course the bread all right let's do
shovel i wish i had ax
axe would be great but it's okay i'll
take one of your finest
wires thank you bud actually you want to
take these
and then i'll take that last wire off
your hand yes
yes please awesome so now if this is as
it suggests it should be i think it's
going to be a better
melee weapon than anything and upgrade
oh sharpen it up baby oh
sharpen it up better material increased
durability
greatly increased durability i'll do
sharpened for now
because that's what i can do i don't
think i can un-upgrade it
but honestly considering i'm using this
as a weapon
and i need to time my hits i'm just
gonna make it sharpened
i'm gonna do that hell yeah and then it
can be repaired
it can be repaired just needs scrap
metal i love that
i love that a lot okay i got plenty of
bandages i got that i got weapons like a
torch
i'm good for the first time in a long
time i'm sitting pretty
really really pretty i don't know how
reliable this is gonna be as a weapon
but honestly just having something that
i made myself
that's not a stick with nails in it
seems pretty dope seems pretty
tight all right let's get a feel for
this okay so it's swinging
in an arc got it let's turn off yeel
generator oh yeah i gotta search
that dude's corpse hey bud oh you have
nothing
oh wait that's the wardrobe oh his
corpus is gone their corpuses disappear
in the night
whatever it's fine so the bridge is full
of demons beyond my nightmares that i
don't want to endure
i guess the best way to go would be to
go down to the village
all right let's do this and again how do
i wait wait let me let me look
is there like controls for how to use
these special abilities
skill menu
oh my god i have a skill menu
all right good that's good to know
that's gonna blow up that's a blow up
you won
hey bud you wanna try on my shovel hey
bud
oh there's two of you oh god i did not
know there was two of you
oh yes yes baby
oh my god hey bud uh oh god right in the
nog okay hey bud
all right try me try me trim out don't
dodge straight backwards won that
oh yeah i'll call yes please and then
stone so those stones actually do damage
but they don't do tons
of damage alcohol yes stick yes okay and
that
didn't knock my durability down too bad
not too
shabby oh and what were they guarding
they were guarding a tank there's got to
be something
a value there ah
yo
all the good stuff oh the good
stuff oh a wreck of a world war ii tank
all right let me
i know there's another tank over here
with some more dudes guarding it i think
i can take them out
yeah so for dodging the rocks it's
probably just better to run a serpentine
pattern
hey blood it's me surprisingly
yeah come on what do you want what do
you want nothing
you got nothing man oh god
oh it's so slow oh god
oh yeah okay there we go i got a heal
though did i get two rags or just the
one
ah you know what i uh it's a heavy wound
anyway
man i really wish my health bar was just
a little bit higher oh wait no no no
god i used to ah i i thought i i thought
i
thought i needed to hold it
all right well let's go fight someone
before the i use up all the healy juice
who's here you yeah yeah come on where
are you going where are you going where
you running
oh mama oh mama
whoa mama where'd you go buddy i need to
whack something i need to remember that
i'm not terrible at
whomping things there he is come here
you you don't even have a weapon
oh you're scared you should be you
should be scared you don't even have a
weapon
all right i'm gonna go back to my house
whoa
whoa hello there you are what
okay is that a corpse that blows up no
it's not
good okay take that i do want that bear
trap let's go bear trap instead of stick
all right let's get back to the house
all right but inventory upgrade yes
please
love it i love it i love that and i love
it
uh a backup weapon just in case this
breaks actually
backup weapon just in case that breaks
and then the weapon magazines oh my
lord all right let's go uh do we want to
try to hit that camp
nah let's go to the village first i mean
time stops in the village so i'll judge
it because i don't want to have to go to
the camp get stuff run back to my house
although it would kind of be on the way
but i i need to go to the village cause
apparently i need to talk to the chicken
lady again
and then i need to do other stuff that
is equally as important
i am the monster in the woods now
everyone needs to be afraid of me
and my shovel it's sharp
very sharp are you naked oh god he's
naked isn't he
oh no all right village hey
it's your friendly neighborhood me
friendly markiplier here
no map it's fine i forget what i need do
i have to get journalers oh my god i
have a journal
oh my god i have a journal a chicken
ladybird the only
that told me plastic belongs to her
brother when i'm missing if you just
give me a photo of the person she saw
him with last local doctor i recognized
the fjorker
okay so that is journal journal journal
journal journal journal journal there's
a lot of pages in this journal
am i really going to be writing this
much in this journal how big is this
book
okay 666 is nothing so there's
absolutely nothing
keys i have no keys okay so i gotta go
talk to the chicken lady and persuade
her
to give me no don't use up the torch
please
and then there's also probably other
items in this town that i can loot and
steal and
it'll all be good oh where does that
lead what did i just see wandering in
the river oh there's so many mysteries
in this game and that's what's amazing
about it is there's so
much mystery and i love it i love how
absolutely terrifying the entire world
is i
i really love it it's it's such a
fascinating using verse
and it gives you basically nothing and
that's
so cool it's so cool i've actually
looked at this one this one's completely
buttoned up
it's it's so cool how much i wanna know
more
like i'm all for mystery i i love
mystery like that i
i think it's so fascinating like there's
story to be gleaned from the environment
there's story to be gleaned from the
people in it
and there's even more story to be
gleaned from how people
like what what people's actions are in
this universe
that's so fascinating and terrifying i
love
this game i really do this is quickly
becoming one of my favorite games
thank you oh thank you
i don't know if those will rot at the
same rate in here
because time is all frozen but we'll see
where's this versus violin oh there you
are
hello i'm sorry it won't happen again
it's okay
it's okay hey it's okay oh
it's not my fault i know it doesn't
sound too great my violin
it's a bit broken i won't play anymore
i'm sorry oh sir have you been in that
hut
the chicken ladies hut you're not afraid
of her you're brave
and have you seen her the pretty lady
she's the most beautiful lady in the
world
i've watched her through the cracks in
the window she changes when i watch her
gets more beautiful i play for her i
want her to be happy
because she doesn't seem to be chicken
lady locked her in that room
she keeps her there she envies her she
won't allow anyone to see her
even me she knows very well that during
the last kapala night
i finished out the pretty ladies wreath
from the river yes sir
the chicken lady knows what it means oh
yes i will become the pretty lady's
husband
we will walk hand-in-hand sir i will
play for her mr sir
i tried to release her but the chicken
lady she chased me off
she always does i look for the second
key and mr jans
but now he's disappeared i don't know
how to get into his house
nod so kind so very kind you're just
like him
my daddy but my papa has changed mister
i
just like my mommy they will not listen
to me they won't hear how sad i am sir
but am i not boring you please don't go
please hear me out don't go
nervous grunting could be heard under
the director perhaps you can help me
leave board nod please find the key good
sir to the pretty ladies room
the chicken lady has it well mr jan also
has it
i saw him recently near the well he used
to play with me when we threw rocks in
the well
and i looked into our reflections while
making silly faces
daddy says to say not to do it else my
face will stay that way
now the water in the well is always hazy
it shows these weird images
the well is here in the village maybe
you'll find him there he's
running around it off and he stared into
the well as if looking for
something someone i must hide now
hide from the chicken lady i'll go to
that place where they used to keep all
the grain
in the southeastern part of the silent
forest
will you bring me the key if you find it
i promise to repay you
me and the pretty lady okay have you
heard about the sow the villagers keep
this sow in the nearby pig shed they
call it the mother of all pigs
i i don't want to see that i don't want
to see that at all they say it's
beautiful but i've never seen it they
don't allow me near it
they chase me off they always chase me
off maybe you would be able to see her
mister
if you managed to get inside maybe you
could take a wee piece of meat for me
i'm never
i don't want to see this i've never
eaten a pig and i've heard it's very
tasty would you take some for me
i don't want to see this pig this is our
doctor yeah he's just as brave as good
as you are
he helped me he's helping us he gave me
this beautiful mask
so i could be healed of my afflictions
maybe you could have one too
i mean seems like you cured your stutter
which is interesting
photo the road mommy once told me about
this road she said
people used to travel in they would
leave their houses and walk
through during the night i was scared of
this story i'm not actually trying to
stutter i'm just actually stuttering
with this i was
afraid mommy will go out too and leave
me behind
all right kid uh what about this pretty
lady
someone in there
oh that doesn't sound good yeah i don't
know
if this pretty lady is what you think
this pretty lady is
oh no oh no oh
n oh no oh no oh no
i could dismantle the window i really
could hey rope that's handy
i need that that's very valuable oh no
hello he said it needed to be done what
did
what it will help he said what will
i don't understand i don't i don't
either
uh burn a mix of herbs in the oven
lavage chamomile nettle keep the patient
warm twice a day one tablespoon of
sauerkraut juice by mouth
great cure hello
what a foul stench that's always a good
sign man it's really
hazy in here oh no
oh no oh no
oh no oh no it's arms and legs are bound
to the chain
oh no oh no oh no
oh no oh no see what the hell is that
about
that's exactly what i'm talking about
what the hell is that about you close
that door be nice okay i do
what what is that about that's so
bizarre
and yet that's just there in this game
in this world
i love it but also what the hell so
weird
okay so i don't know if it's the best
idea to dismantle but also
i don't know if it's the best idea to
let this musician uh
go on with his wonderful dream of
marrying this lady because she
yeah she don't seem good let me just go
about the key route
i don't wanna upset her hi lady uh
remember me what do you need pusso
hungry eh i give you some stew but what
good will it do
lord almighty all right nothing new for
you all right cool
i'm gonna go look by the well have i
been down here
no i have not potatoes good dead rat
i'm okay i'm okay on the dead rat you
know dead rat i'm fine with
fine without actually not with without
all right
kind of a destroyed house looks like the
woods took
over this one oh it's you again hello
hi all right i'll get away from you i
i've learned to
uh take that warning to heart they they
don't like strangers and
i'm starting to realize that i don't
know what i look like because a lot of
these people are kind of freaky looking
but honestly what if i'm horrifying i
have a hat on
i have no idea what i look like
i don't know how many more logs i'm
gonna need i'm pretty okay on wood
i need a key says you nancy drew
this house is looking oddly nice
it's almost strangely nice i don't trust
it at all
this is like the most norm oh i'm gonna
just quickly peep in your wardrobe here
i'm just gonna peep in your oven real
quick just gonna peep in your wardrobe
you don't mind if i take these do you
help yourself whatever you fancy
thanks but don't tell anyone about it
okay
cool uh weird thanks man you're real
nice
uh i'm not gonna open that because i
don't wanna waste lockpicks just yet
i only got so much wire i mean i could
make another one which i'm gonna make
but the jar of meat is interesting i bet
the wolf would love that
could open it with a lockpick i don't
want to use one
man you cannot get in there can you okay
let me actually go back in there
hello hi ah
damn it need a key i bet he has the key
but i'm not gonna take it from him
well i'm not willing to murder for a key
just yet
but i am really curious as to what's in
this place here
could open it with long pick uh
[Music]
i've got two let's do it i i've used
lock picks on
less things oh
dork in here you're
can hear i don't know what it's filled
with but
it's dark and dreary and i don't like it
okay more logs oh
really whoa bread oven a brick oven used
to bake
bread good
nothing really nothing
ah there's gonna be nothing i can open
it oh my god
is this worth it let me work it i'm
gonna put my thing down twist it and
reverse it i'm too curious
oh my god potato oh my god oh my god
oh why oh my god oh my god they gave me
back my
what oh my god oh i know what the meat
is
oh my god this was so valuable but oh my
god
okay i searched every court whoop not
this one
no room in inventory hey let's just do a
little swap rooney
have fun with the bone oh i've got logs
why have i got logs
let me get the bones i don't know what
the bones for so whatever
this has been an illuminating experience
and at least you gave me the tools i
needed back
well let's make my lockpicks back up i
don't know what else you need wire for
so i don't know if there was like a
point to keeping those all right well
that was
oh hey we got logs you know what
that's fine the planks are just as good
okay pig lady uh i guess i could
dismantle this
too strong to dismantle all right did i
go in here
oh i did not ah
oh oh don't mind me
just came for the weapon parts oh my god
don't mind me
oh my god don't mind me don't mind me oh
my god
rags i'll make them in the bandages
thank you okay yeah yeah okay
see you around hey weapon parts are good
don't mind me trees yep trees yep
solution for removing intestinal
parasites pour the petroleum over the
nuts
pour petroleum over the nuts add
propolis
put away for a couple days drink one
tablespoon full
per day this doctor is a genius
a genius thanks for the instructions
really gonna help with my parasites i
appreciate that
and i appreciate you all right let's
find this stupid jensen
some bastard decorated our shrine he
took the stone
oh this must be why the woods are
whispering so gloomily
uh sorry about that one of you
jensen jen son
jensen jimmy
juniper what is that oh the siphon i
don't know what the siphon is
oh never mind the siphon i found that
i didn't know that was something i could
just get good thing i came back in here
okay so there's no one by this well i
could build the well
i need chain oh probably if i rebuild
the well the guy will come back give me
a key
or they'll come back i can talk to them
anyway and then they might give me a key
but you know
what oh there's a basement oh
no i see that oh no okay
great all right well this has been a
delightful experience
and unfortunately that's all the time i
got for this episode so
i'm gonna leave this here i need to get
back to the house drop off stuff it's
only 12
19 so there should still be plenty of
time i
i am in love with this game i'm so
curious just purely curious about what's
happening
that i have to keep playing so thank you
everybody so much for watching i think
i'm gonna see this one through to the
end because i'm just
so into the universe anyway i have no
idea how far into the game i am at all i
really don't know but i'm starting to
get a better grasp of survival
in this crazy place and i've got gun
parts so maybe go bang bang hoodie
shooty so thank you everybody so much
for watching
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]
you